これは
youtube の近い未来の話である
強力な人気を得たユーチューバー国家権力波の力を持つ勢力を拡大し
なるで一つの国のように動き始めユーチューバーたちはお互いを潰し始めた
ロックマンアプリです最高レベルプレイヤーがこの銃はナイスゲームですよで一発だけ
反発担当馬が出るみたい今日もエラーが
ます一見舌で打ってみましょう
はっはっはお入りました
打ってみます
弾切れかもう束だけのチョッパご覧の通りカ所に単発ですてくらい弾が飛んでっている
のがわかると思いますが全部が積んだから2分
これ絶対こう誰もそもそもなぜ私がこんなものを買ったかの理由の説明したよ
まあ今現在ユーチューバーに求められるってものは様々なんでしょ編集力撮影技術
いろんなことが youtube には求められるんですけども
今の youtube の世界で求められるものはそんなもんじゃない今の
ユーチューバーに求められる唯一の力は総戦闘力
編集技術とか撮影能力というの
もう年遅いこれからの youtube の時代に必要なのは戦闘能力
物理的な攻撃が増えてくるやっぱりユーチューバーの音登録者が多くなると実力コース
に出て直接やり合うことが多くなってきたねあーみんなユーチューバー靴に出さないん
ですけど実際かなりグループ的な争いが起きています今の日本のユーチューバー非常に
危ない僕もこのままだと他のユーチューバーに襲われてやられて
今かも知れ物理的にね以上に危険な世界までもゆ誅伐住んでるんで僕は今回その戦いに
勝つためにこういう道具を買ったんですけども
今から youtube 発明をと思ってるそこの君必要とされるもの編集技術でも
ない撮影能力でもない戦闘能力が今のユーチューバー戦闘能力ことはすべてのものを
唯一襲われてもいいように日々の特区5県と行うことが今後の youtube 必要
になってくる
ん
もうユーチューバーきてでは早速戦闘準備に入るよしでは行こう
ユーチューバーは住所特定されやすいのねー
直接言えを襲撃されることが多い
ユーチューバーねー
なんだこのビートボックスさあ
me
まーさーかー
ん
やはり親分です
今日は良させませんよできねぇ j 1 fire
me
戦闘力では俺の方が上だったようですね
た
します
あ
いっ
なんだこの食べ物を食べる大きいノート
上かー
こんにちは今日は昨日したサンバで戦闘民族に
それでも俺は
宜しくお願いい3ぐらいん
ファイバー
こんにちは
th
俺は女を傷つけない主義でね気をつけな
オレキン太キッチンですかっ
あっはい
はいどうもアバンキー rar
ああああああ
ます
今回の企画はこちらに手直し的なん
素なんだこのビートボクサー
まさかぶーっこのビートボックスああ
始めえねー
ふっだ
大地さんこんにちはこんばんはおはよう
土井さん
俺にあなたを打てない目の前に歯ブラシ
n 50に狂ってる
それぞれわー
me
あなたはウィッチうわぁ